You've tried slap chef.
But that just left you hungry
and with a searing headache.
And those other
weight-loss programs
are exhausting.
Can't I just do nothing?
What if I told you you could
with Sleep Gym?
( Amy )
I'd say sign me up.
But what's Sleep Gym?
Sleep Gym is a workout program
where we do all the work.
Huh?
Are you from Sleep Gym?
After we induce you into a coma,
it's off to the gym.
As the Sleep Gym trainers
take your body through
strenuous workouts,
the increased blood flow
painlessly burns
the calories away.
You'll never have to feel
yourself doing annoying things
like hiking,
kickboxing,
the official bootcamp of the
United States Navy Seals.
( whistle blowing )
Move it, you sleepy
piece of ( bleep )!
All right,
see you later, Mom!
( woman )
Where are you going?
The gym.